the history of the jewish people goes
back roughly 4 000 years but in order to
understand the the desire by jewish
people in the late 1800s and early 1900s
for jewish homeland we have to go back
roughly 17 or 1800 years to the year
135 135 in the common era and it was
then that judea was a province of the
roman empire judea is the biblical home
of the jewish people it's the location
of jerusalem and in 135 of the common
era the roman emperor hadrian is able to
suppress a rebellion by the jews in
judea and he after suppressing that
rebellion he expels the jews from judea
so hadrian
hadrian
expels
expels the jews
from
judea and it was actually not only did
he expel them from judea but he actually
renamed the province this province up
here in red was roman syria he merges
these two provinces and calls them syria
palestina so let me write that down so
he renames it syria
syria
palestine
palestina
which is essentially why for the next
1700 years or so and even parts of it
today are referred to as palestine now
we will fast forward over the next more
than 1700 years so we're going to go
more than 1700 years over this period
most of the jewish people are not now
living in what was then judea they have
settled in groups in europe in in in the
middle east in africa there were even
groups of jews who had settled in india
and for the most part they thrived in
their various communities but
unfortunately their history had had a
had a fairly large amount of persecution
of discrimination of kind of using them
as a scapegoat this was particularly the
case in in europe where you have the the
christian church often kind of blamed
the jews on religious grounds you had
you know they were an easy scapegoat
every anytime things went hard you had
ethnic cleansing you had pogroms this
was especially the russian empire as we
get especially as we get into the into
the 1800s was especially infamous and
it's in its treatment of the jews and so
you have this long history of jewish
persecution in fact much of jewish
tradition today is around remembrances
of these various tragedies these various
persecutions and so with that as the
context we then get into the late 1800s
and so let's go to 1860
1860 you have the birth of theodore
herzl
so 1860
you have the birth of this gentleman
right over here theodore herzl born and
he's born to a jewish
a german-speaking jewish family in the
austro-hungarian empire and the family
he's born into isn't particularly
religious in his as a young man he's he
remains fairly secular he's not a
particularly religious person but as he
grows and he he becomes a journalist
he's able to observe the anti-semitism
that especially that's occurring in
especially in the late 1800s in russia
but throughout much of europe in 1894 so
at this point he's 34 years old still a
fairly young man in 1894 in paris he
directly observes he the
dreyfus affair
the
dreyfus
dreyfus affair in which a in which a
french jewish officer in the military is
accused of treason accused of spying for
the germans this leads to all sorts of
kind of public anti-semitism it later is
shown that it was a false claims on on
dreyfus
and some people
would debate whether this directly led
to theodore herzl's articulation of a
need for a jewish homeland but it was
something that he directly observed so
it must have influenced him in some way
it was this and all the other
anti-semitism that he observed either
directly or indirectly his entire life
or even that he was able to read in the
history books and so taking all of that
in and this is coming from a fairly
secular individual in 1896
1896 at the age of 36 he writes der
dudenstadt
der
judenstadt which literally translates as
the jewish state
der
and this was a very articulate
description or or desire or articulation
i guess i should say of the need for a
jewish homeland and a jewish state and
so it's really the birth of political
zionism political
political
zionism
now where does the word zionism come
from well the root is zion from mount
zion mount zion is essentially a hill in
in modern day jerusalem
but the word zion is often equated with
kind of
with with with jerusalem with with the
holy land with kind of the home of the
jews and that would be roughly right
over here jerusalem is roughly right
over here and i stress the modifier
political political zionism is because
there was already a movement to bring
the jewish people back to their their
ancient homeland in judea which would be
referred to as could be referred to as
zionism but it was really herzl who
articulated a a kind of a a need to set
up a political state and start to
organize around trying to create a
political state and i write over here i
quote some of what he wrote in der juden
stott we are people one people we have
sincerely tried everywhere to merge with
the national communities in which we
live seeking only to preserve the faith
of our fathers
it has not permitted us in vain we are
loyal patriots sometimes super loyal in
vain do we make the same sacrifices of
life and property as our fellow citizens
in vain do we strive to enhance the fame
of our native lands in the arts and
sciences or her wealth by trade and
commerce
in our native lands where we have lived
for centuries we are still decried as
aliens often by men whose ancestors had
not yet come at a time when jewish size
had long been heard in the country
oppression and persecution cannot
exterminate us no nation on earth has
endured such struggles and sufferings as
we have palestine is our unforget is our
unforgettable homeland
and this ends up getting huge traction
resonates with the jewish diaspora gives
him the power to essentially the next
year organize in 18 18
1897 the first zionist congress
first
the first
zionist
congress where he's able to bring bring
together like-minded or at least people
who are who are looking to
organize a way to eventually establish a
a jewish state preferably in palestine
and i say preferably in palestine and
it's clear that this was this was the
this was the first choice to go back to
the historical homeland of judea but
even herzl himself had considered
argentina which at the time was was very
open-minded very open towards
immigration there was some talk of of of
of east africa british east africa in
fact the british offered uganda in 1803
in 1903 to the what would later be
called the zionist organization
it was considered at i believe it was
the sixth
zionist congress so these were things
that were actually considered but
palestine was always because of
historical reasons the the hopeful home
of the zionist movement now i fully
realize this is an incredibly touchy
issue regardless of where people
end on on kind of their views of zionism
or theodore herzl some would view him as
a visionary view him as a hero some
would view him as starting the sea that
led to the eventual you know the the
occupation of palestine and and the
settlements that are going on there and
i'll try my best to to to stay out of
kind of picking sides there but
regardless of where you are in in in
that argument it's pretty amazing how
much foresight he actually had and his
ability to kind of get this thing going
even even from the get-go he was able to
he had some conversations with the
ottomans and other folks about being
able to get land in palestine and all of
us it didn't he wasn't successful in his
own lifetime but even after that first
zionist congress which was held in basel
he had he he understood what he was
doing and he was looking past beyond his
own lifetime and this is a quote here
from from his journal and it's pretty
telling we're to sum up the basil
congress in a word which i shall guard
against pronouncing publicly it would be
this at basel i founded the jewish state
if i said this out loud today i would be
greeted by universal laughter in five
years perhaps and certainly in 50 years
everyone will perceive it and this is
amazingly prescient because the state of
israel would come into a reality in in
roughly in roughly 50 years
with that said i and i once again i know
this is an incredibly touchy issue the
one thing that is probably surprising to
to many people is that he
he was not he was not a kind of an
extreme individual and it comes out from
some of his other writing that even
though he wanted this this jewish state
he was a fairly tolerant individual and
he did not view this only for the jews
and he didn't feel that it should be
taken by force or in any other way and
it comes out in his writing right over
here this is from his diary it goes
without saying that we shall
respectfully tolerate persons of other
fates and protect their property their
honor and their freedom with the
harshest means of coercion so protect
their property honor and
using the harshest means of coercion to
protect their property their honor and
their freedom so this is a tolerant
thing to do this is another area in
which we shall set the entire world a
wonderful example should there be many
such immovable owners in individual
areas who will not sell their property
to us so say if we want to go there and
properly buy land but people don't want
to sell it to us we shall simply leave
them there and develop our commerce in
the direction of other areas which
belong to us so he wasn't in the mood to
really get into a confrontation or to
antagonize anyone and he was and he
recognized that there were other people
there that might not want to
sell their land to those that might
settle this this new this new state
and in his later on in his life right
actually shortly before his death he
actually writes a novel about this this
this potential state that that might be
created
and he writes this is written in alt new
land it literally translates to the old
new land
it is founded on the ideas which are a
common product of all civilized nations
it would be immoral if we would exclude
anyone whatever his origin his descent
or his religion from participating in
our achievements for we stand on the
shoulders of other civilized peoples
what we own we owe to the preparatory
work of other peoples therefore we have
to repay our debt there's only one way
to do it the highest tolerance our motto
must therefore be now and ever
man you are my brother